[Music]
a file occurs
lilly Reinhardt knows how to work it on
the pole no really she can work it check
out this pic Lily shared on Thursday
hanging upside down Lily looks fit and
fab rocking a black top matching tiny
black shorts and heels thank you thank
you
Riverdale star wrote overall thinking
really nailing this whole pool thing the
22 year old actress is busy prepping for
her upcoming role in the film hustlers
haven't you heard
it's based on this New York magazine
article which tells the story of a group
of strippers in New York who devised a
plan to steal thousands of dollars from
their wealthy Wall Street clientele the
flick is jam packed with an all-star
cast including Jennifer Lopez Constance
Wu Julia Stiles
Keke Palmer and cardi B Walker the 26
year old who was a real-life stripper
prior to becoming an a-list rapper will
be making her feature film debut JLo
recently showed off this look from the
film which comes out in September on
Lily's birthday no less the release date
for hustlers has just been set for
September 13th
JLo's fiance Alex Rodriguez previously
instagrammed this video of her
practicing her moves holy hotness and
her co-star Julia agrees just check out
what she recently told et about
Jennifer's performance she is phenomenal
in this movie if you've seen it at all
on Instagram her body looks amazing
you've seen the pole dancing there's the
nails in the hair and the makeup but
beyond that opposite her in a scene I
took everything for me me to keep my jaw
closed because she's it's not it's not
JLo it's like a different person and
it's so not a performance like I I
couldn't tell where it began and ended
so I think it's really going to be
exciting to see her in this movie
[Music]